we are entering a new era of dystopian
bs check out the story we got from axios
google and youtube will prohibit ads on
monet and monetization on climate denial
content
look i i i just we've talked about this
with chris martinson
i think you know at least i genuinely
believe we've got very serious
environmental crises on this planet
climate change
dead zones fishery collapse pacific
garbage gyre all that stuff
but man is it a messed up world when
they are coming out right telling you
that there is no more the internet it's
no more
you are a pleb you are never supposed to
be given the ability to speak to the
megaphone and they're going to be taking
that away regardless of whether you're
right or wrong
now it's also important to note here are
they stopping people from climate change
denier or stopping people who are
calling out a lot of the hypocrisy and
the climate change movement because
there's a lot of hypocrisies see it's
very vague generalized language that
gets bastardized and abused so much
because again the rules aren't really
that clear on youtube we don't know the
exact parameters we don't know the exact
words sometimes you say the magic
special words your videos get taken down
without even an explanation sometimes my
videos just get taken down just like
yours tim uh without even a notice
without even a notification so so with
stuff like that happening seeing the
spectrum just being broadened like now
it's this and now it's this and now it's
that like where do you end where do you
even start we don't i mean if you're
going to give guidelines give clear
guidelines let's give let's leave let's
give clear protocols if you deny this
specific
uh assessment or argument i mean that in
itself is anti-scientific you should be
able to argue you should be able to have
a conversation and if you can't question
the science it's not science it's
propaganda uh and i think people need to
realize that more than ever they can't
control people that way and that's the
problem is this this isn't meant for
debate this isn't meant for us to sit
here and have a reasonable conversation
this is meant to silence people and
control people that's this is the state
this has always been the state
centralization is if we can control the
narrative we can control what is said
and we can control the people and at the
end of the day that's what the state
does it centralizes power and it
controls people i think they've lost
control i think the heavy-handedness
we're seeing in the federal government
the desperate maneuvers they're making
is just a sign that
they're they're desperately trying to
assert they have control but more and
more just expose the empress now we're
in the nuclear do you think this is like
mostly brought on by the invention of
blockchain in immutable content and
social media not i think the internet in
general it was it was a ticking time
bomb that you know they used to control
the flow of information perfectly you
had a handful of channels where
information could come from if you were
a journalist with a big story they'd
look at you and say nah we're not
interested
now you have the ability to go online
and like james with telegram put out a
message where people can just click the
link and then it goes up on other social
media platforms yeah i think we're
building our own audience veritas for
the first time i mean that's that's what
strikes me as a
i think this is an age where the loss of
one's twitter twitter account is treated
like the loss of one's life
but there's no i i'm not getting any
coverage on these stories but
everyone's coming to veritas to be
informed that's a new phenomenon so in
the past my
model was to try to get local news
outlets to cover these stories but the
pharmaceutical industry you kidding me
there's actually one local tv station in
kansas
that may cover it only because that's
where the plant or the woman works and
they have to
but um i think there's this phenomenon
where our audience aren't necessarily
fox news viewers tim neither are yours
um just a new audience where we're
informing people one by one and then
another thing i get is well nothing's
going to change nothing ever happens to
these people like a cynicism
and i've said this to um a couple people
i said well listen you got to start
somewhere you change one life you can
change the whole world you can convince
a few people you can make a big
difference but i think the phenomenon
with project veritas is that we're
building this new audience of people who
are being informed because it's
incontrovertible videotaped evidence
it's not my opinion it's
incontrovertible while the machine is
very clearly clamping down on what is
acceptable language they are clearly
violating the good spirit of section 230
they're they're setting forth editorial
guidelines
that's what it is when they tell you
your opinion is not allowed to be spoken
they're saying here are the editorial
guidelines of this platform well it's
even questions and i mean that's what it
gets down to is you can you may not make
statements you may just be asking
questions like hey what about solar you
know solar in space weather do we ever
talk about the the solar energy that's
coming out of the sun in terms of its
fluctuations we never talk about that do
we have an answer for what the ideal
temperature of earth is nobody can
answer that it's been decades and
decades and decades since i was a kid i
mean i remember them talking about a
coming ice age in the 80s and thinking
oh my god you know i was terrified and
that was the thing it was like it was
like live in fear live in fear live in
fear no matter what it was and listen as
a conservationist listen i know very
well that when we look at
the the earth we should be living in
more of a balance but this cry for like
the the balance in the ecosystem and
this i don't know this this idea that we
can not say some things about you know
climate change well this cry comes from
a lot of people who live in cities which
have
absolutely destroyed the natural
environment
i think back to you know 20 or so years
ago where where was the right they
absolutely denied climate change
now they typically accept climate change
but say you know we don't they don't
believe it's man-made or there are
arguments about the solutions pros by
the left or wrong one by one at a time
the arguments from the right veer
leftward as time goes on
there's no there's no uh the republican
party isn't actually making demands of
the legislature repealing things for
instance i've had conservatives say to
me well look we're not going to do it
the left does and force the government
to do things
repeal laws repeal the nfa how about
that one they don't do that either why
not
i don't know because they're uh
they're the unit party and they're
controlled opposition yeah yeah mitch
mcconnell goes i'm gonna hold off the
democrats for about two weeks and then
agree with them
and that's what happens he says i'm
fighting with the democrats and then two
weeks later he goes okay we've come to
an agreement
and people keep voting for the guy they
just wait for the next major news story
ramp it up to 10 and then leave it i
believe and genuinely feel a lot of the
people in the republican party have
stockholm syndrome and secretly want to
be liked by the
by the people that they're supposedly
against like i mean i don't know maybe
they want their book reviewed by the new
york times they want to play on their
turf they secretly wish they were at
that met gala with aoc they want to be
there they wish they were part of that
crowd i really do i think that's the
problem they they want to be liked they
care more about the opinion of the new
york times and their own kids yes yes
and the moment you stop caring is when
you can actually have the will to win
and be effective but that's a
psychological issue a hurdle for people
who are not part of the so-called
mainstream power structure it's hard
even for me i mean i've i've you know
gotten my desire for approval down to a
microscopic
you know bead but
you get more approval because you'd have
to be a sociopath to want to be hated by
everybody but if you want to do the
things that you're proposing you're
going to be hated by
a lot of people who have the power to
make you liked and i and i have to be
prepared to lose i mean i i just passed
a million followers on instagram this
week um and i mean on youtube
we went from 1 million to 1.25 million
subs in like no time and i see your gold
plaque they have not sent me one of
those gold blacks yet
i never got mine
it's sitting in bubble wrap
don't send that out to veritas hold on
hold on here's what i'll do so when you
get those awards those gold and silver
awards yeah they allow you to do a team
purchase so if multiple people work on
your team you can order a custom award
with any name on it from the company so
i think i think i think good good old
team members project veritas and we are
change are going to be getting you know
their their their awards i just think
it's funny that we have 1.3 mil subs and
and our gold plaque is sitting in the
bevel wrap room
at google in california it's like
sitting half open like the manager's
like well you know let's not let's just
verify that those 1.3 million subs are
all real people it's under some some
footnote you know but um i listen i
think that the bottom line is i've come
to see it over and over this is my
mantra today the moment you stop giving
a [ __ ] is and seeking their approval is
the moment you're free to actually be
effective you have to not care at the
first line on your wikipedia it says
far-right criminal doctors tapes it
hurts but you just gotta let it go
because if you do the thing that you're
proposing you're running for office
aren't you yeah god bless you i'm never
gonna run for office your life it's it's
the most i could never do that
i can't do it but we need good people so
thank you i hope you're successful in
your efforts you have to not give a [ __ ]
what they think you just have to do the
right thing
and have a leap of faith and a lot one
of the things that struck me about the
hhs whistleblower and the um pfizer
whistleblower is i asked them aren't you
afraid
of going after pfizer and they both said
effectively i put my faith in in god not
in man
and whether you're a religious person or
not they're taking a leap of faith
they're saying everything's gonna be
okay i'm gonna do the right thing damn
it
and i just think that that's what people
need to do if they're gonna want to
change things i i 99.9 agree with you on
what you said about not caring but i'm
gonna offer up a little a little
different uh go ahead
see i do care what they write on my
wikipedia because for a long time they
claimed on wikipedia that i invented a
live streaming zeppelin
i don't understand why they think i tim
poole and i was working with drones that
i get and i think one of my live
streaming what zeppelin
like a blimp
like they claimed i had a blimp why
would they want straight from germany
i don't know
and it was in my wikipedia for like for
years is that supposed to be defamatory
or
no no but here's the funny thing here's
the funny thing i am so fed up with like
when i read your wikipedia i'm like that
is obviously crazy listen even if it was
true they're opinion pieces that don't
tell us what your organization is and
i'm sick of it so here's what i'm doing
here's what we are doing after a few
years of them claiming that i invented
some kind of zeppelin
and me saying publicly like guys i did
not do this please remove it they're
like you're not a credible source you
can't be used
they finally took it out and i said you
know what i'm gonna do now i'm actually
going to invent the damn thing so
they'll have to put it back in i'll
retroactively make their so that that's
the game i'm playing so we actually have
it we have them the zeppelin is near
completion and we're going to be
launching it we're going to pilot with
certification and we are going to have
the live streaming zeppelin and then
they're gonna have to go back and change
the whole thing all over again because
now it's true now it's brilliant
it's a group i can't wait to see that i
want to be a part of that
but james you brought up a very
important point and if i could kind of
surmise it a little bit it would be that
words only have power when you give them
power and i think we're really seeing a
lot of crazy ridiculous words out there
to the point where everyone's laughing
at the establishment i mean wolf blitzer
he posted this photo of himself and he
looks like a geriatrics bald eagle and
he is and he wrote he wrote this caption
nine months ago he's behind the us
capital quote nine months ago today on
january 6th
2021 an angry mob attacked the u.s
capitol i walked around the complex
today and it was very calm as you know
the perimeter security fence is gone at
least for now you know
you know they were getting ratios
from thomas massey's office the they
were calling it fort pelosi up there oh
wow oh yeah good for them it's
ridiculous but you're you're absolutely
right james you've got to be able to
stand on your own two feet and say i
don't care what they say about me if
you're going to be effective in changing
the culture which is the most important
thing that we're up against right now
you've got to be able to sit there and
say listen they're going to tell lies
they're going to disperse me they're
going to blackball me whatever it is you
got to be okay most people when that
happens they stop they they they start
reacting they start playing on the turf
of the of the opposition
and and to do this you effectively do
have to suffer you have to
uh uh struggle and and and suffer and
and go through pain
and that's it's gonna take pain i think
i think people are gonna have to go
through a lot of pain
uh in order to get to the destination
but the problem i find i've seen people
do this and then they get lawyered up
and then they start to you know you know
you just got to keep going you just have
to keep i mean we're banned on twitter i
want to tell you we are banned on
twitter
but we're trending on twitter
and and actually renders people get
pretty confused by that they don't
understand it well it's because we you
got to get the stories to be so strong
that nobody can ignore it and we
distribute by proxy so we send the the
stories to other people and they embed
the videos and that's what you have to
do and also i think people have to see i
think images
are transformative and and you say luke
the power of words you know orwell
writes in 1984 the party communist tell
you to reject the evidence of your own
eyes and ears it's their final most
essential commandment that's their
number one rule do not believe what you
see in here so i think words are are not
one
thousandth the power of images exactly
if we're gonna if we're gonna win this
battle it has to be through images
that's why we call veritas cinema verite
images
anesthetized they they they transfix
in a way that words do not and
oftentimes you're putting that person in
this in this dichotomy in brooklyn we
had we had left-wing people in brooklyn
sharing our pfizer videos i got messages
from people like hipsters were sharing
our videos they didn't even know like
what project veritas was they're just
like wow this big bad pharmaceutical
company is lying to people that's what
i'm talking about you know you guys also
just had a big exposure like a nursing
home scandal that's right in washington
state yeah and um i saw a lot of
sentiment people were saying it's a
bummer this story doesn't get as much
play because it's not culture war but
it's one of the most serious issues
happens all the time in nursing homes
people forge you know check mark
documents a lot of paperwork in the
bureaucracy so people were just forging
uh check marks to take care of these
elderly people they were not providing
care for
this is what i love they say far right
and it's like you've got stories
targeting mainstream media and big tech
companies as well as nursing homes and
i'm like are what do you what does that
mean are nursing homes secretly
communist organizations yeah and you
mentioned fear i thought that was such
an important point we should do a whole
hour on fear
because
the guy at cnn uh charlie chester said
fear sells well they put the ticker on
the screen with all the people dying he
goes we want we want to be higher i'm
quoting him why isn't it higher why
can't we have the death toll higher from
covid because it'll sell more ads this
is what this man is saying i hate to be
the history buff in in the room with the
anti-federals they call them the bug
bears and the hobgoblins and the mo has
been the same ever since like the the
anti-federalists sit there and they're
profits talking about the united states
constitution right like this is a
centralization of power and what it's
going to lead to is the enslavement of
every man woman and child in the united
states right like what we should be
doing is keeping these states as free as
possible and you know hey in in peace
we'll be friendly and in war hey we're
enemies but this is what it is this is
what goes into
everything that we do overseas i'm i
mean
former marine uh you know served in the
special operations and and saw this
stuff up close and personal and what
goes into warfare before you actually go
kinetic is a
mountain a mountain of fear and division
and if you can fear you make people
fearful and divide them you can conquer
them and that it's just the the absolute
truth but to see you know what we're
seeing now with these people pushing
fear 24 7 ramping it up i mean do you
guys understand like when we talk about
the 95 or 99.5
that they're talking about in terms of
being like hospitalized in terms of
covid or dying of covid right now what
they're talking about is the cdc number
that you're not actually a
fully vast person until 15 days after
your second vaccination so anybody in
that time that has any type of ailment
that goes to the hospital or dies during
that time that's had a shot or two shots
is considered unvaccinated and that's a
number that they're reporting to you to
scare the hell out of you thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you